Dobby had to iron his hands all right
everybody continuing on through my
rewatch of the films and the Harry
Potter franchise it's time for the
second one Harry Potter and the Chamber
of Secrets first thing right off the bat
man this one's long like I had
legitimately forgotten how long this one
is it is two hours and 40 minutes shave
off four credits still over an hour and
a half and sorry two and a half hours
that's that's crazy especially for
something that is ostensibly a kids
movie not like a movie that kids could
go to like intended for kids this is
nuts
I'll talk about some of the reasons why
that is in a little bit but first let's
address the way in which this improves
in a lot of ways aren't the first one
certainly visually the visual effects
are miles better I mean all you have to
do is compare how dobby looks compared
to the cave troll or the Centaur and the
first one night and day zero comparison
this is so much better and it's not just
the CGI creations it's also the
compositing is the green-screen all of
it way better the kids are also actually
becoming better actors I think Harry
most notably in this I think like the
big key moment I remember seeing this in
the trailer being like oh he is getting
better is he's got the dual facing off
against Malfoy and Malvo Malfoy he's
going you scared Potter you wish my ooh
ooh he's getting something and he's
getting good and and all the adults are
still good I will say unfortunate I you
could catch a little bit of it in the
previous one I think his physical
condition is really starting to weigh on
Richard Harris's performance it does
seem like he's having to put a lot more
effort to get out what he's getting out
it is starting to feel like a struggle
for
before like there was a little bit of a
push to get the words out but he didn't
seem tired he seems tired here and I
don't want to make that sound like a
criticism I mean the guy's health was
the guy's health at the time he did this
but it is notable but other than that
all the other adults have now sort of
fallen into a rhythm in terms of their
parts speaking these words because I
mentioned that before some of them kind
of I don't know I don't want to say
tripped over some of the nonsense
fantasy words but you could tell they
were like weren't quite natural with
them yet they pretty much all are now
I'm including some of the new ones we
get kenneth branagh has Gilderoy
Lockhart now I remember being
disappointed initially because they were
originally talking to Hugh Grant who I
think also would have been great
although I suspect you grant would have
been slightly less outwardly boisterous
he would have just gone for more of a
yes ungrate and I know it thank you and
a bit less of a Oh
which is what Branagh goes for and that
were either one would have worked for
Lockhart but it hit Broadway Eddie
what is an interesting figure in general
because I think the guy's definitely got
an ego but I think he also knows he has
an ego and I feel like in this he is
sending himself up at least a little bit
and I think he knows that so I I dig his
performance and I have a an awful lot of
fun with that and like I said all the
all the actors are improving tom felton
as as Malfoy he still stuck with a lot
of arch very Oh gotcha
you know sort of lines but you know he's
it's feeling more like dialogue and less
like less like he's reading it off a
script and of course we also get Lucius
Malfoy his dad jason isaacs perfect
casting I mean perfect witches I've said
before is really the strong suit of this
franchise in general there is one bit of
casting that doesn't quite work for me
not that the casting is bad but like the
performance is quite gel for me even at
the time I saw it for the first time not
a huge fan of Moaning Myrtle like
especially at this point because if you
watch this especially coming off the
previous one
everybody's starting to feel a little
bit more natural and a little less
stilted in the way they're delivering
their lines and then you've got the
incredibly artificial and and overblown
and almost kind of hyper real emotional
level of Moaning Myrtle and it it
probably would have worked that I mean I
know the characters in it but that style
of performance would have flown better
in the first one than it does here and
also random bit the woman who plays me
Moaning Myrtle was almost 40 when she
was in this so you know there's that now
I mentioned the length on this and that
it that is kind of a sticking point this
is an odd one because it's one of the
shorter books it might even be the
shortest book and yet the movie is so so
long and I think a big part of that is
because this is one of the ones that is
much more an active mystery than the
others there's usually a mystery element
in most of the Harry Potter stories but
I'm not sure you would actually describe
a ton of them as structurally being
mysteries because you know the first one
had you know all this groundwork to do
all this world building and just move
things along in that way this one
despite the fact of not having to
reestablish everything and do the
exposition over is part of the reason
it's as long as it is is because since
it is a flat-out mystery ie who who is
the heir of Slytherin who is doing this
and like and when I say proper mystery I
mean it's not just people wandering it's
like we have red herrings we have
suspects we have all these people who
maybe it's them and then we have to go
into and find out oh no it's not we know
it's not because of this now we have to
go to another suspect and there were red
herrings in the first one like Snape was
a big red herring but it was really just
him he was just the one now we have red
herrings that we have to dispel with
Malfoy we got to go through it again
with Hagrid and then you know once we
actually get yo Tom Riddle in the diary
we have to explain how all that works
and I mean you could practically call
Aragog a red herring you know there's
there's a lot more stuff that basically
is harder to streamline I
I probably could have streamlined it
better than they did the thing is this
thing went in production quick this
thing started shooting three days after
the first film came out now obviously
they were working on the script prior to
that but I I can't help but feel that
the very quick turnaround on this is is
probably part of why it it feels like
you could have used like one or two more
passes on the script not to completely
restructure but just to streamline it
just a little bit because there's stuff
in here that in the bigger picture of
the story is a lot of wheel spinning
where ultimately the characters hat
aren't really in a different position
than they were before at the end of a
segment that's basically you know how
the various red herrings go we go
through this entire thing with brewing
the Polyjuice using the Polyjuice
getting into the Slytherin and so
they're in common room talking to Draco
also that we can confirm oh well it
wasn't Draco so at the end of that what
do we know that we didn't already well
we still don't know who the heir of
Slytherin is do we have a new suspect no
so and that's not to say like you should
cut that completely but for how little
ultimately gets learned by either the
characters of the audience compared to
how much time it takes to go through the
thing as currently structured that's
kind of what I'm talking about it's out
of balance and the same with Hagrid as a
red herring because we have to go
through the entire thing of finding the
diary
Harry gets his flashback in the diary
sees Hagrid what's going on with there
they suspect Hagrid they talk to Hagrid
Hagrid gets taken off to Azkaban they
follow the spiders get to Aragog
find out that Aragog wasn't it then have
to escape Aragog that is a lot to go
through to ultimately learn oh well we s
we still don't know much of anything so
and like they learn a little but again
for how much time is spent to learn as
little as they do and to have that
basically happen a couple of times with
different red herrings I think that's a
big part of what eats up the time and
again like other than just streamlining
it there aren't a ton of things that you
could just remove completely from this
because like I remember
noting like the proper plot doesn't kick
in until almost 40 minutes 45 minutes
into the film that's when the very idea
of the Chamber of Secrets gets
introduced and we have our first
petrification victim which is mrs.
Norris and the thing is though as long
as it takes for the plot to kick in
properly and at first is weird it's like
they don't have to reestablish all the
all the exposition why is this taking so
long well because we do still have a
fair amount of stuff that needs to get
established and most of this is gonna
end up being relevant later so we do
have to meet the Weasleys and get a
better sense of this family and not
their great I really do love Molly
Weasley especially I love how she can
turn on a dime shouting at one of her
kids and then turning to Harry or Ginny
and just mean like oh hello sweetheart I
love that she can do that and then
Arthur is you know he's just lovable you
you get where the kids get a lot of what
they of how they behave um but you know
that does matter and then you know we
need to introduce Gilderoy Lockhart we
need to introduce Lucius Malfoy we got
to get them back at the school we got to
get them into a rhythm of what they
think is normal before we can disrupt it
so as much as it's weird that it takes
40 minutes for the plot to kick in
I don't like maybe with a couple more
passes and just streamlining and
tightening the scenes maybe they could
have gotten it down to half an hour but
it still would have been a little while
before the plot really kicked in no
matter what but I for my money with just
nickel and diming not massive
restructuring not removing whole scenes
but just nickel and diming tightening
streamlining just finding a way to to
have a scene accomplish two things as
opposed to needing two separate scenes
to do a thing apiece you know from a
narrative structure standpoint they
probably could have shaved minimum 20
minutes maybe even half an hour off this
thing just just with little tweaks
across the entire thing so it's one of
those things it's very odd because no
individual scene necessarily feels
bloated but by the time the film's
winding down you're like oh man I feel
like I ran a marathon which it might be
part of the reason why I think I
sometimes
the impression that this is not one of
the better loved entries in the
franchise and I think that sort of
feeling of other we still going that you
have by the end of it might be part of
that but it's still very good and aside
from the fact that it it is kind of
tiring by the end pretty much everything
is better than the first one
the kids are better there's less
exposition that needs to be done so
which means the writing is less clunky
which means the dialogues less clunky
everyone's settling into their roles the
effects are miles better than in the
first one so you you do sort of get this
sense of everyone is a climate um selves
to disfranchise that they're gonna be a
part of going forward but at the same
time it does feel a little bit like a
slog in a way that the first one doesn't
the first one has its issues especially
at this point looking back and looking
at some of those effects and hearing
some of those line readings it's like oh
wow I'm really glad that this wasn't the
only one and they got to keep going in
and improve this but it never feels like
oh man hmm
you don't check your watch during the
first one you'll probably check your
watch during this one which is a shame
because other than needing to be
tightened up I think it is better than
the first one on most measurements but
you know it is that it is those little
things that just needed to be just
tighter and but what we have is what we
have and what we have works and I think
it's gonna be interesting talking about
Prisoner of Azkaban because I know in a
lot of ways that's the one that
everyone's like and this is where the
franchise got good and a lot of people
ranking is like the best movie of the
life I've seen some people even say it's
the only great movie in the series we'll
see what I think got a revisit I have
some contrarian opinions above about the
third movie so that there's a set up in
a hook to get you to come back and watch
the next one but chamber secrets I think
it's I think it's good I think it's
solid it's just it's just too long and
to refine it would have taken
a lot of little touches as opposed to
big excitations of major plot elements
or or anything like that um oh I like
the other thing I'll mention is we never
get to see this performer play Tom
Riddle again but they the the young
actor who plays Tom Riddle from the dire
in this really good and obviously in
he's way more intimidating than that
face in the back of quirrell's head was
that was just kind of weirdest slightly
creepy like we get a lot more
personality out of this sort of frozen
memory of Voldemort as much as it annoys
me that they kind of cut my favorite
dialogue exchange which is which is
Harry just sort of poking at him like
you're a vague memory of somebody who
couldn't beat me at his full power what
are you really gonna do like and Harry's
still scared when he says that when he
says his equivalent of that in the book
but he's like poke at this guy you know
I've seen what you're like now you're a
parasite you're barely alive and I kind
of missed that but despite that I really
do like them confronting each other and
I like their their exchanges I just
shove that randomly in the middle at the
end while I'm trying to do wrap-up
chamber of secrets have you seen what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there was a
whole bunch of stuff to do down there as
well because there is buttons and links
you can you can like subscribe I
definitely appreciate that
there's a patreon I appreciate that as
well helps improve the channel helps me
cover my bills and additional to that
I've got a book I've got merch there's
my socials down there all sorts of stuff
click on links they'll take you places
or don't you don't have to because at
the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]